let's say you want to communicate with a
friend you'd probably use a phone to
send them text messages
in the same way your brain cells
communicate using neurotransmitters like
acetylcholine
which plays a key role in processes
ranging from memory
to muscle contraction prompted by an
electrical signal
a neuron releases acetylcholine into the
synapse
acetylcholine then binds to a receptor
on the opposite neuron
relaying the signal but what happens to
acetylcholine once its job is done
enter acetylcholinesterase a dimeric
enzyme that specializes in breaking down
acetylcholine
using a triad of three specific amino
acids
zooming into the active site we can see
two of these amino acids
the critical serine and the histidine to
which acetylcholine binds
with the help of a water molecule the
enzyme breaks acetylcholine down
completing the signal transmission cycle
however as we
age the number of our cholinergic
neurons decreases
leading to reduced acetylcholine levels
and the onset of alzheimer's disease
one innovative treatment for alzheimer's
involves inhibiting acetylcholinesterase
with molecules like glantomy
preserving the acetylcholine in the
sinus
galantamine blocks all entry into the
active site
allowing acetylcholine to continue its
signal transmission
unscathed diving into the active site
we see galanta means shutting down
operation through binding to the
critical searing
however because the lantamine only binds
through hydrogen bonding
this inhibition is reversible with an
estimated 5.5
million americans living with
alzheimer's understanding the
biochemistry of inhibition
is a key step to bringing those numbers
down finally
it's important for individuals
consistently experiencing symptoms like
confusion and memory loss to seek a
medical diagnosis
as soon as possible giving their brains
a head start
on the path to recovery